le prix payé pour l'étoile de grand-mère
ne cesse d'augmenter la preuve la maison
Christie hier à New York a mis aux
enchères un Picasso et des monnaies
tirées de la collection des garesman les
ventes de cette seule soirée dansante
totalisé plus de
285 millions de dollars
nous sommes en pleine saison des encas
d'oeuvre d'art à New York la maison
Christie's a vendu ce tableau de monnaie
27 millions de dollars ce Picasso
trônait dans l'appartement new-yorkais
d'Edgar Brown qui est décédé en novembre
dernier il a été acheté plus de 8
millions si les montants semblent
démesurés c'est pourtant bien la valeur
actuelle du marché selon Alain
Lacoursière l'appétit des Chinois et des
Russes pour les œuvres des grands
maîtres ajoute à la pression sur les
prix plusieurs oh les gars je suis
maintenant on s'aperçoit que des
sociétés à numéro ou des gens qui
viennent acheter ou qui vont acheter
leur téléphone et c'est des
millionnaires des pays de l'Est au
Canada la maison Eiffel tiendra à la fin
du mois un an d’œuvres d'artistes
canadiens en vedette on retrouvera entre
autres le mieux ou encore se réappel
estimé entre 400 000 et 600 000 $ une
évaluation conservatrice souligne la
directrice de la maison chargé de la
vente ces deux artistes là faut vraiment
partie d'un groupe très select
d'artistes canadiens dont les œuvres
peuvent franchir le cap du million en 40
ans la valeur de certaines œuvres d'art
a bondit de façon spectaculaire ce
Marcel Ferron par exemple a été acheté
150 dollars en 1979 il vaut aujourd'hui
entre 10 et 15000 dollars alors ça
demande vraiment quand même
la croissance du marché et que dire de
cette toile d'Edwin rollgate son
propriétaire l'a acheté deux dollars
l'automne dernier dans une vente de
garage de Laurentides une trouvaille
d'environ 15000 dollars mais elle aussi
elle a le potentiel de se vendre plus de
30000 alors une belle une belle histoire
là les amateurs d'art qui n'ont pas les
moyens de se payer un telux pour moi
tout le moins venir les admirer les
portes de la maison Eiffel à Montréal
seront ouvertes au grand public jusqu'à
samedi ici Vincent Maisonneuve
Radio-Canada Montréal